if you had to be one word that
summarizes what they are what the favor
is that cool almost the opposite i
submit tough if i leave you one word
right it was too busy I think I think
reactions is gaining at the higher
because then we use our way and opposite
to describe it okay so what's the actual
summary I'm not going to give you the
full ready for this one because it's
quite famous but the idea is that object
exert that son that's a really important
word that's the word that we attach two
forces okay I'm equal force on each
other in opposite directions so there
are two remains two key words right
equal opposite I think I think that
particular wedding is for every action
there is an equal and opposite reaction
okay so that's simple example this is if
you have two things right like say two
planets okay so look or maybe maybe a
son okay so no plan actually no no no I
take that back let's go back to a planet
Earth let's make it cuz this isn't
easier pig let's make it the earth in
the moon nothin moment now quite
obviously that there is pulling on the
moon right which is why the brune is
stuck in orbit around us we know this is
an obvious fact right so there's a pool
from the earth on the moon yes but at
the same time the moon is pulling on the
earth right now we have so much more
mass in proportion to the room that it
doesn't seem to change us all that much
but does changed in a visible way and if
you go to the beach or sere what's the
way tides thank you so the water around
the planet oh this is a terrible
presented but the water around the
planet is a lot easier to move then like
all the rocky hard stuff right so that
gets bogged down this way or Boulder
whichever way the moon is
okay so the moon is also tugging on the
earth okay and in fact it's actually
wrong to say that the moon orbits the
earth because the moon doesn't orbit the
earth the moon is orbiting if you take
the the masses of these two objects
right this is so much more massive but
you know in your a debuff then somewhere
in between here there is what we call if
you too if you add these two obvious
together there's the center of mass of
the entire object of the pair of outlet
okay now because that's so big the
center of mass is actually within the
earth okay but the point is that the
earth is not just spinning on itself
it's actually kind of wobbling a bit as
well right the moon is orbiting that
spot but so is the earth the earth is we
going around on this point to right and
so obviously you know if you had a
bigger object bigger no more equally
matched objects the center of mass would
not be on either will be right in the
middle so these guys are going to be
going round and round it's not gonna
look like ones go around the other
because they're both going around this
lead okay semi mascot Marisa
okay now sorry an equation equal
opposite forces really easy easy
equation if you got object a and object
be right one of them has a force for its
equal and opposite to the other force
that's it that's the equation that's
going to be a started for it for a lot
of questions